here's why McDonald's operators are
leaving in droves McDonald's likes to
write off The Exodus as simply pent up
demand from the pandemic but in reality
there was a pivotal event in 2018
remodels McDonald's offered to pay 55 of
the renovation expenses for the affected
14 000 U.S restaurants which came out to
a total of six billion dollars this
means that the average cost to renovate
each store was a whopping
779 thousand dollars out of which
operators responsible for 350 000 for 40
percent of operators this was completely
unfeasible as the remodel experience
would put them in danger of not having
their leases renewed based on McDonald's
own Financial requirements